1066! The start of the royal family on these beautiful islands. Well, there were kings and mini
statues before and druids before, and Pangea before, but we have to start somewhere
and a millennium ago is far enough - if Ethelred let the Undecided out,
then so be it.
William the Conqueror conquered in the 'Norman Conquest' - Norman standing for * French *.
Because it was the days of yore, they had many children, but to keep it simple, this tribe leaves
tree many of them out on every branch because not every child matters.
For example, Willem had three children that we think are important: Willem II, Hendrik I and Adela.
If you have watched the royal succession video - if not, click here - then you know
that formal rules for passing the crown will be established, but for now it is one
'free-for-all', home-team advantage for the eldest son, but never forget: greater-army diplomacy.
After the death of William the Conqueror, William II became king.
William II did not marry, and one day with his brother he died in a "hunting accident"
that Henry I gave the crown.
Henry I had at least 26 children, of whom only two were 100% legitimate. He stated that his
daughter after him (after his son died in a shipwreck) and swore his knights
Honoring Empress Mathilda by inserting a needle through their hearts, hoping to die, stabbing a needle in their eye
- * but * when Henry I died while Mathilda was in France, many ignored this while her
cousin Stephen rushed to Westminster, using faster army diplomacy, to be the first to be crowned.
Empress Mathilda possibly came back and started a decades-long civil war - that
an impasse was because turtling was an effective RTS tactic in the 1100s.
While she ruled part of the island, but because Mathilda never had an official coronation
its status as a monarch has been challenged.
Well, because Stephen's children were either dead, or uninterested, or a nun - his crown went
after his nephew, Hendrik II, who had four sons: Hendrik de Jonge, Richard Leeuwenhart,
Jan without Land ... and Guffrey (guess who died before his turn).
Henry II saw the history until then of conquest, assassination (perhaps), capture, wear and tear
war - and decided to wait until after the death of the current king before sorting out
of the next king did not work.
So Henry II changed the system and Henry the Younger crowned him, with which
the rule of two called: one is none. Two is one. If it is important, you need a backup.
It was a good plan for stability, helped by the popularity of the young king, but unfortunately
- the apprentice rebelled against the master, united his brothers - what still caused
a civil war of disputed monarchs, during which Hendrik the Younger died of dysentery, Hendrik
the Elder died of a fever and Richard I took the crown.
After Richard, Jan and four eldest son successions came in a row: from Jan to Hendrik III (place
Magna Carta here) to Eduard I (de Stelt) to Eduard II to Eduard III.
In fact, Ed II was overthrown by Isabella of France AKA, the she-wolf of France AKA
his wife. After the removal of her husband, she worked as a regent for their son. All of
these arrows skip a bit of complexity.
Eduard III had five sons: Eduard the Black Prince, Lionel, Jan, Edmund and Thomas,
none of whom would wear the crown.
When Edward III died, his throne would have gone to the Black Prince, but he was then
dead, so the crown went to his boring son Richard, now the second.
There is some drama lama fuss around Richard the second where your English teacher
you might be forced to read about it - but, spoiler alert, the end of history is always the same:
greater army diplomacy, this time from Henry IV who gets the crown and Richard II
hunger in captivity.
Another Hendrik before we arrive at the Rose War:
A war that brings fear (and boredom) into the minds of history students throughout the nation
those dealing with * this * family tree get 'simplified' to explain why everyone was angry,
but the shortest version ever is that the great-great-grandsons of Eduard III fought each other, even though
one of them was dead for part of the fight, but we can't talk about that now
so from Henry VI to Eduard IV to Hendrik VI to Eduard IV. End.
Edward IV, on his deathbed, left the crown to his son. But since he was twelve he needed protection,
so Richard, his "best" uncle in the world, promised to take very good care of him.
Eduard V quickly disappeared under suspicious circumstances that cause Richard
Richard became the third.
But he did not remain king for long because Eduard III's great-great-great-grandson,
Henry VII took the crown, attached a ring to Elizabeth of York to that royal
to get identification and begotten Henry VIII - splitter of churches and women.
Henry VIII thought it was high time to formalize the rules of inheritance, he wrote
out in his will - which actually said: oldest boys first, only girls if none
are boys - and Parliament approved the rules.
This should have made everything tidy, but we almost entered the horrible one
messy time ...
... Because Hendrik's son lived just long enough to ruin it - inheriting the throne
At the age of 9 there was, of course, a cunning patron who arranged it all, but he decided at the age of fifteen
that his father's rules were stupid and his sisters were stupid and that his cousin,
Lady Jane Gray, instead, had to be the next monarch.
Then he died and Lady Jane Gray became queen with her sweet sixteen, sort of - on a disputed
status way for nine days, until she was beheaded by Maria, the first, really official, nobody
doubt the queen.
Maria had no children and passed on the crown to Elizabeth I who was the second
became a queen in a row ... to have no children either. But, no problem because Lady Jane was Gray
at the ... o. Yes.
Well, this is the point where we acknowledge, Scotland exists. They have their own
did a royal thing that for our purposes joins the British branch when the great-great-granddaughter of Eduard III
got married in it in the 1400s and then goes like: Jacobus, Jacobus, Jacobus, Jacobus, Jacobus, Maria queen
der Schotten, Jacobus. Which brings us back to the 1600s.
Importantly enough, the sister of Henry VIII also married in this line of the family, some English
gives legitimacy points in the eyes of the English Parliament, which asked for the James of Scotland
to borrow, which made him king of two countries with two numbers in his name, depending on where
your vandaang counts.
Jacobus had a son, Charles I, and you would think that this unification of the monarchs means that
the terribly messy time is over.
But no.
Because Cromwell.
Cromwell did not like kings and beheaded Charles I. He declared: no more kings and he made himself
the Lord Protector, which was in no way like a king - even though he was the boss and
it was a hereditary position that he passed on to his son.
But the Cromwells didn't stay - mainly because his son was a rural squire
rule 0 did not follow: keep the army happy - what the son of Charles, Charles II, allowed
restore the monarchy.
Charles II had many children, all of whom were bastards, leaving his brother, Jacobus
II was the next in line. But James was * Catholic * and since Hendrik had split the church, had
Catholics little popularity. But well enough, he had decent Protestant daughters, one of whom
was married to a Dutch prince, who by nature was the grandson of Charles I.
Extra English legitimacy points, plus, who doesn't love the Dutch?
With James so unpopular and Willem and Maria so popular, the army and nobility invited
the royal chief about to "invade" and James II fled.
Willem and Maria reigned as co-monarchs, but without children the crown went to Queen Anna,
who also did not produce heirs, but not for lack of effort - she was
* seventeen * times pregnant.
Now that they were back in a situation without royalty, the Parliament decided that it was really
Seriously it was time to lay down the inheritance rules to prevent pretense from all
branches of this messy tree started fighting for the crown.
Parliament did a royal 'reboot' to clean up the mess, and they defined Sophia of Hanover -
Jacobus' granddaughter two numbers as the new starting point for all claims to the crown.
The rules finally remained, ending the terribly messy time.
George I, the son of Sophia, was the first king under the new rules, and then his son George II,
to George III, and even though he lost America and his mind, no fear, the rules are here,
and so the crown went calmly further down the family tree, to George IV, who none
had surviving children, after Willem IV who had ten children - all bastards,
then through his dead younger brother to Queen Victoria who started her reign in
1837 and who made it just over the finish line of the 20th century. A little double
was an impressively long time given the state of medical technology at the time. After the end of her
period, the crown went to her son Eduard VII to George V ...
to Eduard VII who * finally * breaks through this neat (and rather boring) line of legacy
commit a scandal: marry a citizen. An American citizen! American one
citizen who was * divorced *! *Twice*
:: Gasp ::
The divorces were actually a problem and incompatible with the role
of the monarch as Head of State * and also * the Church of England in the 1930s. Edward resigned
to his brother George VI - who was unwilling to take the crown, and then too
the Second World War and the subsequent demolition of the British Empire had to oversee - what health
of the young king, who died at the age of 56 and left the crown to Elizabeth the Second, in 1952
at the age of 25. Seven years older than Victoria, her great-great grandmother, was on her coronations
day, but in September 2015, Elizabeth became the tallest reigning queen in not only
the Briste history, but also in world history.
From Elizabeth II the crown will continue to Charles, the longest heir apparently in the British
history to his son William, to his son George.
And that, is a brief history of the royal family.